نعود الان الى واقعه اقتحام ااا بن كثير
لباحه المسجد الاقصى لنصلط الضوء على
مكانه الاقصى الدينيه والتاريخيه
بدا بناء المسجد الاقصى في القرن السابع
بعد فتح القدس في عهد الخليفه عمر بن
الخطاب وهو اولى القبلتين وثالث الحرمين
الشريفين بعد المسجد الحرام بمكه المكرمه
والمسجد النبوي الشريف في المدينه المنوره
يمتد المسجد الاقصى على مساحه نحو 14
هكترا في الجهه الجنوبيه الشرقيه من مدينه
القدس القديمه المحتله ويحده غربا حائط
البراق او ما يسميه اليهود بحائث مكه
يقصد بالمسجد الاقصى كل ما هو داخل السور
الباحث والجامعه القبلي وقبه الصخره
والمصلي المروانيه ومصلى باب الرحمه
والاروقه والقباب وغيرها كل ذلك يسمى عند
المسلمين الحرم القدسي الشريف ويعتقد
اليهود انا ما يسمونه الهيكل مدفون تحت
الحرم القدسي وتسعى بعض جماعتهم المتطرفه
لاعاده بناءه الاقصى اذا هو احد ابرز
عناوين الصراع وقد تعرض منذ الاحتلال
احتلال فلسطين لا اعتداءات اسرائيليه
متلاحقه ففي عام 69 اشعل متطرف يهودي
حريقا في الاقصى ادى الى احتراق الجامعه
القبليه ومنبر صلاح الدين وفي عام
1996 اعلنت حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو فتحه
نفق ضخم تحت باحات الاقصى يبلغ طوله نحو
450 متر
واواخر سبتمبر ايلول عام اقتحمها زعيم
اليمين الاسرائيلي حين اريال شارون باحه
المسجد الاقصى تحت حراسه قوات الاحتلال
وفجر ذلك شراره الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه
الثانيه الانتفاضه الاقصى
وفي يوليو 2017 حاولت السلطات الاسرائيليه
نصب بوابات الكترونيه عند مداخل الحرم
القدسي لكن تصديا الفلسطينيين افشل هذا
المشروع وفي مايو ايار عام 2021 ادت
مواجهات عنيفه بين قوات الاحتلال
والفلسطينيين في باحات الاقصى الى اندلاع
حرب من استمرت 11 يوما بين اسرائيل وحركه
حماس التي قصفت مواقع اسرائيليه في القدس
بالصواريخ لاول مره
القدس الشيخ ناجح ابكيرات نائب مدير عام
الاوقاف الاسلاميه في القدس اهلا وسهلا بك
شيخات ما المطلوب الان اسلاميا وعربيا بعد
الذي جرى اليوم
يعني علينا ان ندرك تماما بان ما جرى
اليوم هو
محاوله استعراض عضلات من اليمين المتطرف
بالتنسيق مع حكومه نتنياهو رغم نفي
الخرقانيه وارسال رساله كونه للخاميه
تعتمد ان يحرم على اليهود دخول كامل ما هو
في داخل السور وهناك يافطات علقت منذ عام
تمنع وتحرم على اليهود دخول منطقه المسجد
الاقصى بكامله همم بكامل مساحته 144000
متر مربع الا ان هنا قفز على هذه الفتوى
من قبل الصهيونيه العالميه التي استغلت
الدين من اجل تحقيق ثلاثه اهداف الهدف
الاول هو تغيير الرؤيه البصريه في المدينه
التي يسعى الاحتلال الى جعل القدس كعاصمه
وديها لمشروع الدوله اليهوديه ولابد من
تغيير هذا هذه الرؤيه التي تعطيك بان
الطابع هو طابع اسلامي منذ زمن ادم وورثه
الانبياء يعني حينما صلى النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم بهذا المكان والانبياء جميعا
بايعوا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم واعطوه
هذه الامانه والنبي نقل هذه الامانه الى
الصحابه الذين كلفتهم اكثر من 25,000
صحابي توفوا من اجل الحفاظ على هذه
الامانه وجيل بعد جيل حافظ همم حافظت هذه
الامه على هذه الامانه كونها هي المدخره
لكي تكون عاصمه يعني العالم العالم
باختصار عندما يتحدث الجميع على ضروره
الحفاظ على الوضع القائم ما هو هذا الوضع
القائم باختصار رجاء
يعني الوضع القائم كان هناك تفاهمات على
ان الوضع القائم هناك
وصايا اردنيات تقوم هذه الوصايه على ان
الاوقاف الاسلاميه في القدس تقوم على
اداره المسجد كامله
والشرطه الاسرائيليه لها السياده الامنيه
وليس لها سياده الاداريه ولكن منذ عام
2000 وبعد اقتحام شارون حاولت سلطات
الاحتلال ان يكون لها ايضا سياده اداريه
تتدخل في شؤون همم اداره العمل في شؤون ما
يجري في المسجد الاقصى وبالتالي بدات
تتدخل في ادخالها المقتحنين وفي زياده
اعدادهم وفي زياده الرموز يعني اليوم هنا
حينما اا يدخل عباره عن وزير على مستوى
وزير يمثل سياسه هو دخل كونه غير وزير
والان كوزير غدا ستاتي الحكومه كامل
الحكومه اليمنيه المتطرفه بمعنى به الغاء
القداسه هنا بالتالي تغير الوضع القائم
الذي كان متفق عليه وبالتالي نحن امام
خطوره كبيره جدا يعني هنا التحدي التحدي
ليس للفلسطينيين هو التحديد امه الاسلام
كبير امانه هي امانه اسلاميه شكرا لك شيخ
ناجح بكرات من القدس شكرا لك